c'est un joli coup remporté par
industeel ce fleuron de l'industrie
creusotine pulvérise son dernier contrat
record 50 mille tonnes
de tout plaquer commandé pour équiper
des plateforme d'extraction gazière au
moyen-orient dans un contexte
hyperconcurrentiel et après un an de
tractations
cette commande apparaît comme une vraie
bulle d'oxygène pour l'industriel depuis
deux trois ans les contrats sont un peu
difficile à accrocher bombe dans
beaucoup d'atouts au creusot beaucoup de
compétences beaucoup de savoir faire
maintenant il faut aller chercher les
contrats il faut qu'on arrive à être au
rendez vous de nos clients et c'est vrai
qu'on avait bien besoin de d'accrocher
une telle commande alors pour satisfaire
le client
il faut produire gîte et en quantité
pendant deux ans 120 intérimaires
recrutés sur le bassin d'emploi du
creusot vont devoir prêter main forte
aux équipes de cette filiale
d'arcelormittal la ligne de tôlerie doit
tourner à plein régime
on a recruté donc à la fois des soudeurs
des gens pour la découpe plasma puisque
seul chien a besoin pour pouvoir
fabriquer notre rôle est aussi de
régions contrôle qu'on habite à prendre
à terme dans les ateliers de kyo les
gens sont pas seuls on les attaque par
compagnonnage tels que chaque personne a
un parent et tout au long du cursus
intégration le parrain donc 1 évalue la
capacité donc la personne peut apprendre
le métier pour qu'à la fin on puisse
valider ses compétences est né c'est
travailler tout seul dans les
installations
reste que ce regain d'activité ne
concerne qu'une partie des ateliers de
musique soit un quart de sa capacité de
production
optimiste l'industriel compte sur un
prochain décollage des commandes en
provenance des secteurs nucléaire et
militaire pour se refaire une santé